how's it going rez welcome back to e
losses the reason why I haven't been
playing this is because there was an
update coming out yesterday took my old
data download I don't know why is [ __ ]
slow and J I hope I don't have to replay
everything we'll see in a second aren't
you excited I'm up looks like we don't
have to replace [ __ ] huh
this makes me happy ok the problem was
the screwdriver doesn't work for a lot
of people you're supposed to use it on
the radio so what we browse needs to do
let's party yeah logs party with me holy
[ __ ] did I just throw that into space my
god I'm [ __ ] but all the other ones
go
this is the mystery we'll have to solve
late ok whatever they're not [ __ ]
around I need to go to my home I mean
what is this what's going on here I do
quite frankly
well well where is the batteries see
pedes see how is that in the answer
what don't throw me to space peers Shh
hey tell me where the batteries is and
no one needs to go to space but feed I
know
complain no it's it twice you tell me
where the [ __ ] they are
or you go to space ok Peter I tell you I
tell you it's over there alright I'm
gonna
it better be [ __ ] right about this
huh if if the battery is that radio is
not there well it's gonna be in trouble
Space Launch for whoever [ __ ] it's
not yeah it does have cornflakes those I
might I might forgive him there you are
you disgust me but as I didn't know
plate onto a jar space to you
enjoy space [ __ ] that this is
what I started yes here it is
if you're not only told me from the
beginning goddamn well man okay let's do
this
yes it's working cool very cool I'm
[ __ ] things up in the dark it's like
I've taken a magnet now this could be
useful and I know exactly what it's
gonna be useful for it will i thought
you are in space bids i love you i want
to play with you okay fine I'll give you
one more chance
god damn you will like I did you seen
aliens up there see many aliens what
really how were they like they were
powerful just like Justin Bieber oh okay
that's makes it I love how the wheel has
a shadow but I don't wait does that mean
I don't access how do I look like wheel
you very beautiful P it's very beautiful
in B thank you thank you I do my best
I mean I haven't showered for a couple
days but that's okay that's it but all
that at one point I mean it rained
earlier I don't have to shower all the
time cpt I agree good you better I'll
[ __ ] throw you the space love this
music very spooky very very spooky see
please please stop agreeing with
everything I'm saying see Pete see I'm
sorry yeah it better be
I'll drop you off this bread kids please
reconsider don't do it I'll do it
why you so mean to me pits all I want to
do is love you that's okay that's okay I
love you too pls finalmente so no Ari
ari Ari vamos it's do not throw up this
is so tempting okay I'm not gonna do it
I'll keep you for now alright so I need
to throw a will up here I know how to
throw in like that or throw them like
that I'll do like that I worked out well
you're an idiot what I mean kids throw
better next time I have no idea where he
went
you could go to space for all I know
Jeanne is pure
strikes egg that was beautiful I almost
got a tear for myself oh I forgot about
that stuff
well you landed perfectly capias I do my
best
alrighty then oh it is the time has come
for us to grab in the [ __ ] someone
thought it was a good idea to to throw
down the key here so we'll use these
magnets so we don't have to touch in the
[ __ ] [ __ ] genius
do I really have to go sir clothes like
oh that's disgusting
yeah Jo strike that is beautiful
alright this is actually kind of spooky
but now we can go in the house for us
finally if you know lament that so no
going out those in the house ha ha
I'm scared well you're coming with me I
don't like this huh ash of all that
could be useful yeah Oh ashes alright
I'll take some ashes if you know I'm
saying bah
so now we have a shovel the question is
what the [ __ ] are we supposed to do with
a shovel
maybe I should search some more before I
leave ok I clearly did not find
everything here there's a chest here I
could open that it started 20 years ago
all right so I'm gonna summarize that
book instead and then the ones who wants
to read it they could just read it that
there's this kind of cult people were
disappearing from the town this person
was watching them they all were crazy
and here's my number so call me maybe
okay I see some darkness ah this is so
creepy
graveyards at night alone no bueno
no zombies not today zabis alright so we
need to dig something up the question is
what which grave should we dig up not
Nicholai Nicholai Nicholai
well I guess I can finish my own grave I
mean why not oh hello what is that doing
there I found that all by myself I'm
such a Jetta well where are you what is
going on here oh that must be the man
mentioned in the journal huh do you have
something for me don't jump in my face
please that's a key inside his pocket oh
that is a wolf what why was he looking
at me like that why didn't the heavens
no no no do it take it back take it back
hey I don't want it if the werewolves is
gonna [ __ ] me I don't want it take it
take it take I take its don't argue with
me no [ __ ] I don't even know where this
goes the mayor's house of course
okay gross I'm a little scared
I wish we'll was here well we're gonna
go to the mayor's house we're gonna
attempt go into the mayor house I'm sure
we'll be fine
don't worry I'm gonna die okay huh okay
you know what werewolves aren't that bad
it's probably just a regular wolf with
really evil okay there's a light there
which means hope light is hope am i
right
okay the mayor's house which one is the
mayor's ass I don't even know it's got
to be the fancy house okay then we made
it to the village without the werewolf
sir hello
No hello I'm sure it says somewhere okay
creepy music that's okay we're done
desta is a mayor mayor Otto's Halawa
where am I
could this be it could this be it this
could be it
I never even [ __ ] been here oh my god
I am alright let's close this door
because of werewolves uh hello that's a
cute little house I'll go there wow I
can actually go in here and I actually
progress by going damn I'm not genius
just follow what's cute rest is through
that in a horror game and you'll it'll
be fine okay Beryl we got a cutter and I
don't even know I miss wheels so much
okay this is the mayor's house of course
he lives in a big fancy house I shut him
down
can I write this it's a bicycle no [ __ ]
okay
something smells nice in there it's mint
alright I get I'll take them in I don't
really know what's hideout all I know is
I know comfo eye battles how you done oh
what's making that noise
werewolf are you watching me well what
was that is that a window that's an open
window
I that cracking noise is cracking me up
whoa what are you going blank I thought
we were Oh black you are smart man all
right we're going in and there's glowing
cornflakes oh it's it's washing hey
washing thing is there anything in the
bathtub
it's not anything in the top pooper okay
we're fine we're fine
come here washing come here all right I
know why I want to [ __ ] with me you
gotta go through washing what is this a
nightmare it is a nightmare just like
this game by pot you were a good friend
everyone was a good friend
oh I forgot my friend washing tired
tried try it is I your friend denied I
don't get it
I really don't get your name man I don't
know what's up with it I just don't know
nice painting man broke ChaCha's lamp
huh
okay let's go we have some lighter fluid
and this we can [ __ ] [ __ ] up
oh that's right brush I just we're gonna
[ __ ] things up oh we're gonna [ __ ] a lot
of [ __ ] up
all right I need to check everything
thoroughly in this game come on tried
let's get out of here this is creepy
that's really really creepy bras alright
we're going downstairs no I'm coming
down
do not [ __ ] with me or pillows this is
actually kind of hot you made it alive
I'm so happy oh man I'm so happy pillows
I love you come here give me a hug hi
Wren what are you doing alright
well I know what I tell you to [ __ ] off
jeez it's locked I may need to find a
way to pick the lock huh ok that's ok
hey it's a kitchen
what is what's going on here kitchen yes
that eyeball [ __ ] what is this place ha
who do you think I am Jack oh do you
think I am I need to find a way to pick
the lock okay that's cool hey later may
your house alright so we're gonna use
the clip sir on this [ __ ] I removed a
small metal wire from the bicycle rim
maybe I can use this as a de neige a
spare track again
[Applause]
[Music]
Janey is pure genius
alright let's do this bro
let's use it here I need to bend them
first I know exactly where I can bend
them ok I gotta go back to I don't know
which house but I know there's the house
that has a I don't know what they're
called in English honestly I don't know
what to call in Swedish either I just
hope the werewolf doesn't [ __ ] with me
on the way there but we're gonna have to
find out in the next episode like a
ferret tougher and died let's guy coming
out tonight and I'll see you next
episode I think thousand bro
way
suck in there
[Music]
I ain't you
yea-ah